hey this is pressure Locker you open a
brand new deck of cards you notice the
cards are arranged in increasing order
by suit you give the deck a proper
random shuffle the question is how many
cards on average do you expect to be in
the exact same position as before you
shuffled the deck give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for the solution so we'll get
started by asking how many different
ways are there to arrange fifty-two
cards you can arrange them in 52
factorial different ways which is
approximately 8 times 10 to the power of
67 this is an astronomically large
number if you were to count one
arrangement of a deck of cards for every
second of the age of the universe you
would still only count less than 10 to
the 18 possibilities so what this means
is we're not going to solve this problem
by counting out all the different
arrangements this also leads to a bit of
trivia if you give a brand new deck of
cards a random shuffle it's very likely
because there are so many different
arrangement of cards that you will end
up with an arrangement of cards that no
one has ever seen before so now let's
try and solve the problem well first ask
how often is the first card going to
remain in the same position I'll call
this the correct position well the first
card is equally likely to be in any of
the 52 spots in the deck so there is a 1
in 52 chance that the first card will be
in the first spot similarly it's equally
likely that every single card will have
an equal chance of being in the correct
position the second card has a 1 in 52
chance of being in the second spot and
so on
so to solve this problem I'm going to
define a random variable X sub K that
equals 1 if the caithe card is in the
correct position and it equals 0
otherwise this will allow us to define
the problem in terms of these random
variables the question how often how
many cards do we expect on average to be
in the correct position can be redefined
in the notation that we want the
expectation of the sum of each different
card being in the correct position by
the linearity of the expectation
operator this will be equal to the sum
of the expectations now how often will
the first card be in the correct
position that'll be the same thing as
the expectation of X sub 1 but we just
reasoned that each card has a 1 in 52
chance of being in the correct position
so we figured out that the expectation
of each different variable is equal to 1
divided by 52 so we can substitute the
value of 1 over 52 for the expectation
of each individual random variable we
now have 1 over 52 added to itself 52
times therefore we have a sum that's
equal to 1 and that's our answer
so there's actually surprising to some
people in a proper shuffle of the deck
we actually expect one card to be in the
same spot as before it's not true that
in a random shuffle every card will end
up in a new position we actually expect
one card to remain in the same spot did
you figure this out thanks for watching
this video please subscribe to my
channel I make videos on math and game
theory you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Walker and if you liked this video
please check out my books there are
links in the video description